[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAUREN MYTTON: Policy is, in
part, a very technical issue.
And when we talk about
policy, we normally
talk about things like
ANRs, frame rates, hardware
utilization, and so on.
And those terms are great
for helping us to deconstruct
and measure quality, but
they don't necessarily
help us to connect with users.
And users are where
everything starts from.
So I want to start there, too.
Put your user hat
on for a moment.
Think back to the last time
you were playing a game
or using an app, and it didn't
work as you had expected.
Maybe the game frame rate was
erratic, maybe the app crashed.
Whatever it was, I'm sure
you had no difficulty
in recalling that experience.
And I'm also pretty
certain that most of you
will remember the app or
the game that caused this.
In fact, some of you possibly
don't use that anymore.
You've uninstalled
it as a result.
So it's probably not a
surprise to any of you
when I tell you that low
quality apps are ultimately
less successful apps.
But let me be more specific,
since I have the data to do so.
Apps with the lowest stability
get 26% more one-star reviews
from users than those
with the best ability.
Users also engage 4%
less with these apps.
And if you are a game developer,
the story's a lot worse.
It's actually
about twice as bad.
Users leave you 58% more
one-star reviews if you're
unstable, and your
engagement drops by about 8%.
Now, looking at
these percentages,
you might think, well, the
numbers 4 and 8 seem quite low
compared to the 26 and the 58.
But when you think
about engagement,
think about what
it actually means
to you and your business
to increase engagement
by 4% or 8%.
Think about what that
actually translates
into in terms of monetization.
And you'll realize that
a 8% drop in engagement
or even a 4% drop is
absolutely not trivial.
These are really
not small effects.
Play cares so much
about user experience
that, as we've said in the
past, your app's behavior
on these metrics as well
as some other core vitals
has an impact on your
discoverability in the Play
Store and on your eligibility
for editorial collections.
So that brings me to
something that you all
have in common here today,
which most people do not--
you're developers.
You have the amazing
power and privilege
that comes with being able to
create experiences for others
on Android, whether
on mobile or beyond.
And if you're here
today, then you
care that those
experiences are good ones.
Now, my colleagues
and I also care, too.
We see it as our
shared responsibility
with you, the Android
Developer community,
to create the best possible
experiences for users on Play.
And we know that quality
isn't an end in and of itself.
I'm sure you've all got bigger
business goals than that.
But what this shows
is that if you
want to achieve
your larger goals,
you can't avoid
thinking about quality.
So we have tools that we've
developed on the Play Console
to help you measure
and manage our quality
across your
development lifecycle.
There are two primary tools--
the pre-launch report
and Android vitals.
The pre-launch report allows
you to test your app before you
release to real users.
It works by installing your
APK on a number of devices
in our Test Lab.
And then we can either
call your app randomly
or you can tell us
through scripts or game
loops, the paths that
you want us to take.
Vitals identifies issues for
real users, primarily, users
that are in production, but
also in your test tracks,
if you have enough users.
These are tools that many
of you are already using
and some of you have come
to office hours to discuss.
And they help you
with quality not just
when you first launch your title
but for every subsequent launch
as well.
And we know from
the feedback we've
had from developers that
these tools are really,
really helping you to manage
your quality in service
of those larger goals.
We have a couple of
case studies here
from app and game developers.
But we have many more.
But we also know that quality
is a job that's never done.
And you've given us plenty of
feedback about where we still
have more work to do.
There are three particular
things that we hear from you.
One, you want us to help
you anticipate issues
before they happen, before
they actually reach your users.
Two, you want us to help you
prioritize the issues that you
know about, which ones should
you tackle and in which order.
And three, having
made those decisions,
you actually want us
to help you fix them.
You need us to help you
more with the debugging.
So today, we're
going to talk to you
about some of the ways in
which we're helping you
in each of these areas.
And some new features that
we're excited to talk about
to kick things off, we're going
to talk about anticipating.
And I'm going to introduce
my colleague James to do so.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMES HEATHER: Thanks, Lauren.
My name is James, James Heather.
I am an engineering manager
on the Play Console team.
The first new
feature that we want
to talk about today in this
important area of anticipating
quality issues is in
the pre-launch report.
Now, one of the key
strengths of Android
is its openness and,
consequently, its availability
on a huge range of hardware.
There is a vast array of
different Android models
out there.
That's a good thing.
But, of course, it comes
with an associated challenge
for developers.
You've tested your app or
your game on physical devices
that you have and on a
variety of emulators.
But how can you be sure
that it will work correctly
on real end user devices that
you don't have access to?
This is where the pre-launch
report, or PLR, comes in.
As Lauren said,
PLR will give you
information about how your
app performs on real hardware
devices based on our crawls.
This is what it
looks like when you
see the results of our
crawl in the Play Console.
We can help you find stability
problems, crashes, ANRs,
either device-specific
or more general ones,
performance issues-- are you
consuming high levels of system
resources--
violations of Android
accessibility guidelines,
devices on which your app
just doesn't look right--
we can provide
screenshots for you
to check from real hardware--
and security problems,
if your app contains
vulnerabilities that
we can identify.
But now, we have one more
signal that we've added
to help future proof your app.
Some of you will
remember that last year,
we made an announcement
that we would
start restricting usage
of non-SDK interfaces
from Android P onwards.
In case that doesn't ring a
bell, let me briefly explain.
Every SDK contains an API
that you're supposed to use
and internals that,
as a developer,
you are not supposed to rely
on because they might change
and that will cause crashes
or unexpected behavior.
The Android SDK is no exception.
There are internal methods,
private methods and fields,
that aren't intended to be
used by external programs.
In P, one of the
changes that we made
was to start restricting
access to some
of these non-SDK
interfaces in order
to make sure that apps don't
rely on internal state that
might change.
And that should bring
benefits to end users
in terms of the stability of the
apps that they use every day.
We're going to be restricting a
few more of those in Android Q
to improve long-term
stability even further.
You'll be able to find the full
list on the Android Developers
website.
Our aim is to do this in the
most stable way that we can
so that we don't
crash your apps.
We've started by
restricting interfaces
that weren't in use at all.
And we're adding
public alternatives
whenever we find use cases
for these restricted APIs.
The restrictions on
devices running Q
will mostly be based
on the Android version
you're targeting.
So it doesn't mean that users
will start seeing crashes
when they update to
Android Q. But it
does mean that you'll want
to be aware of these issues
before you release an
update that targets Q.
This is important even
if you're not explicitly
using non-SDK
interfaces in your code
because we found
that in some cases,
the calls are being made by
third-party libraries, where
you might not even be aware
that you're making those calls.
The blacklist will apply
to all apps on a device,
regardless of what
the target SDK is.
The APIs on the
blacklist are ones
that we believe
are not being used
by any external
developers anywhere
with apps in the Play Store.
And the restrictions are
there to stop developers
from starting to use them.
So as of right now,
you will be able to see
Android compatibility issues
in the pre-launch report.
The first change to PLR
is in the Overview page,
where we've added
some new information.
You can see the extra entry
for Android compatibility
in PLR, where you'll
see that in this run,
we've identified four
errors and five warnings.
Further down the page,
you can see more details
and a link that brings you
to the full list of issues
we've found.
You can also find the
information on the tab
at the top that used
to be called Crashes,
but we're now
calling it Stability
because, really, it contains
a lot more than just
crash reports.
And you can see how we call
out two types of issue--
errors, meaning use of APIs that
are restricted and will cause
your app to crash, and warnings,
which indicate use of APIs that
are unsupported and so
could still misbehave
and might be restricted in
future versions of Android.
And in order to make
it as easy as possible
for you to prioritize
and fix the issues,
we help in a number of ways.
First off, we give
the type of issue--
is it fully
restricted, so it will
break in Android P onwards--
or unsupported, planned for
restriction in Android Q,
or unsupported and
might be restricted
at some point in the future.
Secondly, we list
each specific API
that we find in order of
how often the API was called
so that it is likely that
the most important one will
be at the top.
And finally, we give
up to 20 of the stack
traces where that
API was invoked
so that you can locate
it in your code base
and find an alternative
approach that doesn't involve
using non-SDK interfaces.
All of this functionality
is live now.
And by the end of May,
you'll be able to test
your apps on devices
running Android
Q in the pre-launch report.
But there are a couple of things
you might need to think about
to get the most from
this, and, in fact
to get the most from the
pre-launch report, in general.
First, some apps need
credentials to get
beyond an opening login screen.
And as smart as our
crawler is, it probably
can't guess your password.
What we recommend that you do
is create some test credentials
that you don't use
for any other purpose.
And if you then enter
those credentials
into the Settings tab
of PLR, we are then
able to use them to log
on when we crawl your app.
And that will enable us
to test more of your app
and go further.
Secondly, if you're
developing a game,
then you might
want to provide us
with something that
helps us to test
the key parts of
the game that are
beyond the reach of a crawler.
In order to do that, you
can build a game loop
and share it with us.
You just need to
ensure that you respond
to an intent of conduct,
google.intent.action.testloop,
and use that to
initiate the game loop.
That means that we can run
the important sequences
of your game on devices that
you don't have access to and let
you know what we find.
For the visuals, this is
particularly important
because you can then
download the entire video
stream from PLR and
check that the game looks
as it should do on each device.
Thirdly, don't
forget that issues
on new versions of
Android can show up
not just in compatibility
results but also in crashes.
In vitals, you can find crashes
on a given Android release
by filtering.
And in PLR, you can find
crashes on particular versions
of Android just by
scanning down the results.
Note that it's really
important that you
do this early since issues
that you have on the latest
version of Android will
take some time to propagate
to a large number of users.
So you're unlikely to see
them showing up in your trends
in the early days.
But that's good
because it gives you
a chance to fix them before
they become serious problems.
All of these features in
PLR are available to you,
and in fact,
automatically run for you
as long as you submit
your APK to a test track.
So I'd strongly recommend
that you build this
into your testing cycle.
Once you have a build
ready for testing,
upload it to an alpha or
beta or internal test track.
We will then run
our crawler over it.
And you'll have time
to act on any findings.
This gives you a
strong start when
it comes to this key
area of anticipating
quality issues in your apps.
I'm now going to hand
over, to my colleague, Fed,
to talk about
prioritizing those issues.
[APPLAUSE]
FEDERICO COLLA:
Thank you, James.
Hi, my name is Federico Colla,
and I'm an engineering manager
on the Play Console Team.
As Lauren mentioned
earlier, prioritizing
which quality issues
to address is an area
that we know you still
find challenging.
And over time, we have
developed a variety
of tools in the Play Console
to help you measure and manage
your app quality across
the development lifecycle
and to evaluate
your app performance
from one update to the next.
Among these tools, under
vitals, is a powerful solution
to manage the performance of
your app or game in production.
As a quick reminder,
Android vitals
is an initiative by Google
aimed at improving the stability
and quality of Android devices.
It is powered by the data of
more than 100 million users
who have opted in to share
their data with Google
and with you, our
developer partners.
Android vitals cover
five performance areas--
stability, rendering, battery,
and since the last I/O,
startup time and permission.
Within these areas, we
have more than 15 metrics
that represent the app
quality that your users care
about the most.
Things like crash rate,
and ANR, and so forth.
Moreover, each metric
can be broken down
by at least three dimensions,
like APK version, OS version,
and device model.
In other words,
Android vitals helps
you understand the
performance of your app
as experienced on real devices
in the hands of real users
in the real world.
But while vitals
is very powerful
and has seen great
adoption since launch,
one thing we heard from you is
that you needed more context
to help understand how
your performance stacked up
against the industry and, more
importantly, your competitors.
When we first launched
vitals two years ago,
we introduced the
concept of bad behavior.
This helps show how your app's
performance really compares
with the worst offenders.
But this was not enough.
So last year, we launched
category benchmarks
to help you understand how
your app or game compares
with the top apps
in the same category
or any other category
of your choosing.
Category benchmarks
apply to all vitals.
And for each of them, we
show three percentile points
to show where your app
falls in the distribution.
And we also introduced
category benchmarks
to other parts of the Play
Console, like ratings.
But we keep hearing
your feedback
that you want even more concept,
and the category level detail
is often not enough.
So this year, we are
very excited to introduce
a new feature in
the Play Console,
developer-selected
peer benchmarks.
With this feature, you can
now define a custom set
of eight to 12 peers and see
how your performance compares
across all of the
Android vitals.
And to make things
easier for you,
we use the metadata we
have about apps and games
to intelligently
suggest a set of apps
that are similar to yours
for you to compare with.
However, you can remove
apps from the set.
You can add other
suggested apps,
or you can search for new
apps by name or package name.
And privacy is very
important to us.
And this feature
is no exception.
So we have carefully designed
this product with privacy
in mind, defining a set of
rules to protect your vitals
and performance data.
However, in the
interest of giving you
full control over your data,
we provide an option for you
to opt out of having your
data available to peers.
Note, though, should you opt
out of sharing your vitals data,
you will be unable
to use this feature,
missing out on the valuable
insights about your app.
So once you select a
set of relevant peers,
you can compare the
performance of your app
with a median of that peer set.
And you can do so across
all of the vitals reporting
services, like
the Overview page,
Details page, and as well as
all the time series reports.
And we are also taking the same
functionality and intelligent
peer selection from vitals
and extending it to ratings.
As with vitals, by using
a predefined or custom
set of up to 12
peers, you can see
how your rating performs over
time against your competitors.
And you can even drill
down to a country level
and see how your rating
compares to competitors
in your most important markets.
Now, there is a lot of
information in Android vitals,
and we just
introduced even more.
So here's a couple of key
takeaways for you to remember.
First, take a moment
to define a custom
peer set for your app or game.
A good starting
point is to pick app
that are similar to yours
from a functional or technical
perspective.
And while comparing your
app with competitors
is very useful, the
peer benchmark features
can also be used to define
an aspirational peer set
for your app.
So a group of apps that
already perform at the level
that you like to achieve.
Finally, the apps
and games ecosystem
is constantly evolving.
So make sure that you
come back to update
your peers set on a regular
basis, like every other month.
And the final thing
worth calling out
that is particularly
relevant to many of you
with limited bandwidth
or who don't regularly
engage with the vitals
section in the Play Console,
to ensure you are aware of
the most important changes
to your app's
technical performance,
make sure you sign up to
the vital email alerts.
This way, you will be made aware
of any critical performance
issues that need your
immediate attention so you
can ensure a solid
experience for all your users
in production.
We are announcing more
benchmark-related features
across the entire Play
Console this year at I/O.
If you want to learn
more about this,
don't miss this talk
that is scheduled
for later this afternoon
on the same stage.
And now, please welcome
my colleague, Joel,
who will tell you more about
some exciting new features
in vitals and beyond.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JOEL NEWMAN: Thanks, Fed.
Now, while pure benchmarks
are an incredible addition
to the console, they're
really just one of the ways
that we're working to help
you with prioritization.
Hi, my name is Joel Newman.
And I'm a product specialist
on the Play BD team.
I'm here today to talk to
you about another new way
that we're working to help
you with prioritization--
this time, specifically,
as it relates to app size.
As some of you may
be wondering, well, I
didn't ask for help on app
size, why should I care,
and fair enough.
Let's give it some context.
We know that you as a
developer are likely
spending lots of time, effort,
and money to acquire new users.
You leverage paid and
organic media to drive users
to your store listing page.
You optimize the
assets on that page.
Hopefully, you're doing
store listing experiments,
all with the intent
of increasing
the likelihood that a user
will click the Install button.
And that's where the
journey ends, right?
Unfortunately, not.
There are a lot of
things that can happen
between the time a user clicks
the Install button and the time
they can actually
fire up your app
and start to engage with it.
Recently, we
conducted an analysis,
in fact, that found
that almost 30% of all
install requests are
not actually completed.
Let that sink in
for a minute, 30%.
It's pretty surprising, right?
Well, what's driving this?
When we dug deeper,
we found that there
are a number of factors at play,
but they're all generally tied
to one of three things--
space, time, and cost.
And all three of these are
directly tied to app size.
Now, what do I mean by
space, time, and cost?
Let me touch on each, briefly.
So first and, arguably,
most important is space.
The fact is that
many users simply
don't have enough
space on their devices.
When we analyze the over
2 billion devices on Play,
we found that about three
in 10 have less than 1 gig
of free storage available.
And surprisingly,
this was not just
an issue in emerging markets.
This was also prevalent
in developed markets,
like North America
and Western Europe.
Without enough
storage on device,
the install simply fails.
And the larger your app is, the
more likely that is to happen.
Now, what about time?
Now, obviously, the
longer a download
takes, the higher
the probability
that a user will simply
lose interest and cancel
the download.
It also increases the
probability of disruptions
in connectivity,
something that's
a particular challenge
in emerging markets
where networks are
sometimes unstable.
And the final issue is cost.
So, unfortunately, the abundant
Wi-Fi and the near limitless
data plans that most
of us are used to
and simply take
for granted, it's
not a reality for
many of our users.
With limited data
allowances, many users
will simply cancel and
install as soon as they
see the expected download size.
So given that app size
impacts all of those factors,
the total size of the
download on device,
the time to download,
the cost to download,
it's no surprise that app
size has a significant impact
on install success rates
and, accordingly, total
overall installs.
But what may be a surprise
is that we can actually
quantify it.
We did a recent analysis of all
the installs in the Play Store.
And we found that for
every three megabyte
reduction in download
size, developers
saw a 1% increase
in total installs.
And similar to what
Lauren was saying before,
you might look at 1% and be
like, oh, that's no big deal.
This is not really
a meaningful change.
Let me tell you.
You talk to anybody in
your marketing department,
anybody who focuses
on user conversion,
this is a meaningful
change in total installs
that you as a developer have
incredible control over.
So given the fact
that app size can
have such an incredible
impact on install rate,
the total number of
installs, and, accordingly,
all of the downstream business
KPIs that your business cares
about, this is a really
important metric for you
to pay attention to.
And that's why I'm
proud today to announce
that you'll be introducing app
size as a full-fledged Android
vital.
If you navigate to the Android
vitals section in the Console
today, you'll see
that there is now
a dedicated app sized subsection
with a myriad of reports
to help you understand the
overall health of your app
size.
In these reports within
the app vitals section,
as well as within
Statistics page,
you'll see two really important
metrics that you as a developer
should be paying attention to--
app download size,
which is the size
of the download of your APK
over the wire, which is directly
correlated with install
conversion rate,
as well as app size on
device, the size of your app
after your app's installation
on device, which is in turn
directly correlated
with uninstalls.
We'll also show you how your
app size changes over time.
So you can assess how
things like new releases
might be impacting
your overall app size.
To bring two parts of
today's talk together,
Fed talked earlier
about pure benchmarks.
And as I mentioned, app size is
a full-fledged Android vital.
So accordingly, I'm happy
to announce that you'll now
be able to compare your
app size against that same
custom-defined set of peers so
you can see how you stack up
against the competition.
For those of you who've
adopted the app on the format,
we go even one step further.
In an all new app
size breakdown report,
we provide a detailed breakdown
of the components of your app,
highlighting how
much of your app
is code versus resources
versus native libraries
so you can assess the
underlying factors that are
driving your overall app size.
Even more, we conduct
an automated analysis
of your bundle.
And we deliver a
tailored custom set
of optimizations ordered by
expected app size improvements
to help you prioritize
what to work on next.
So I just talked about
a lot of the information
that we're going
to be delivering
in terms of app size.
So what specifically should
you as a developer do?
So I think there are two things
that I would recommend doing.
First is, just
purely at a baseline,
go into the new app side
subsection in vitals,
get a sense of how your
app size is performing
to try to assess what impact
app size might be having
on your overall business.
Second, if you have adopted
the app bundle format,
you should go into
that optimization,
go check out that list
of optimization tips.
These are concrete,
actionable steps
that you can take to
quantifiably reduce
your app's footprint
and, accordingly, boost
your installs.
Now, I just really glanced at
a very high level on app size.
If you want to go one or
even 10 levels deeper,
I strongly encourage
you to check out
the dedicated session
that is happening tomorrow
at 8:30 AM on Stage 2, where
we'll cover some of the details
on app size as well
as the tools we're
developing to help you
monitor and improve it,
as led by some of
our product managers.
Now, let me quickly get
back some of our asks.
One of the top
pieces of feedback
that we heard from you as
it relates to app health
is that you love PLR.
You love Android vitals in
terms of identifying problems.
But you sometimes struggle to
identify the underlying causes.
Well, I want to let you know
that we hear your feedback.
This is a consistent thing that
I'm hearing from developers
all the time.
And so today, I'm happy to talk
a little bit about a feature
that we recently
introduced that should make
debugging significantly easier.
It's called PLR
and Vitals Linking.
Now, as Fed mentioned
earlier, Android Vitals
is a tool to help you
track the performance
of your app in the wild.
Now, because we're
collecting data
from real devices in
the hands of real users,
we often have to
redact the information
we show in the interest
of user privacy.
So here, for example, is
some of the information
that we might surface for
a crash in Android vitals.
You'll notice that although we
show the stack trace, we redact
the exception message in
case it contains private user
information.
Now, this information
as it is currently
may be helpful at base
level for still getting
at some of the underlying
issues, but for some of you,
it may just not be enough.
Now, in contrast to
vitals, pre-launch reports,
on the other hand, work by
running your app on devices
situated in the
Firebase Cloud Test Lab,
automatically navigating
through the app,
capturing exceptions, and
generating logs as it goes.
Now, because this
testing is occurring
in a controlled
environment, we're
able to expose key information,
such as the exception
message, that might otherwise
be redacted in vitals.
Additionally, beyond
the exception messages,
which can be very
helpful in debugging,
whenever an anomaly such
as a crash or an ANR
is detected in PLR,
we automatically
capture screenshots and videos.
These can be super
helpful resources
to help reproduce the
issue and, hopefully,
to get at the underlying cause.
Now, wouldn't it be
great if you could
go straight from a real world
crash identified by vitals
to that same crash in PLR with
all of its associated data
and resources?
Well, now you can.
With the recent launch of
vitals and PLR linking,
whenever a real world
crash is detected
and Android vitals that
we also see in a PLR test,
you'll see a link between
vitals and the same issue in PLR
are with its associated
data and resources.
So you can debug
more effectively.
And it's worth noting
that this is not just
a one way connection.
We've linked pre-launch reports
and vitals in both directions.
So now if a crash occurs
in pre-launch reports
and it's already happening
in the real world,
you'll be informed.
And you'll be able to
jump from PLR to vitals
to see the real world
impact of the crash.
So how would you use this?
So we think this can be
really helpful for you
in terms of prioritizing
issues that I identified
in PLR because you'll be
able to quickly assess
which issues that PLR
identifies are having real world
user impacts today.
So Android vitals
and PLR linking
is a really powerful tool.
But it's really only as powerful
as the amount of your app
that we're able to crawl.
So I want to quickly
reiterate the message
James said earlier, which
if any part of your app,
especially if it's
at the beginning,
is behind a login screen,
please be sure to provide test
credentials so PLR can more
effectively test your app
and run crawls.
Similarly, vitals
and PLR linking
is only actionable if we're
able to intelligently parse
your stack traces.
So if you're using Pro
Guard or another tool
to optimize or
obfuscate your app,
be sure to upload a mapping
file for each version.
This will enable us to show
useful stack traces, reliably
de-duplicate crashes, as well
as really unlock the potential
of vitals and PLR linking.
So as you can see, by
connecting PLR and vitals,
we're taking one
more step forward
towards helping you with
debugging and making it easier.
We hope you'll check
out this feature
along with all of our
new app size reports,
as you continue along
your app health journey.
So before we wrap
things up, I'd like
to hand it back to
Lauren, who's going
to recap a little bit of
what we talked about today.
[APPLAUSE]
LAUREN MYTTON: Thanks, Joel.
So we covered quite
a number of things.
We talked about vitals
and the pre-launch reports
for those of you who
haven't used them before.
And we walked through
four new features
just to help you connect those
features back to the two tools
we've got right now.
You can see here that
Android compatibility
sits in the pre-launch report.
Peer benchmarks and app
size are found in vitals.
And clearly PLR
and vitals linking
can be accessed from
either direction.
And I want to give
you another slide.
And I've seen many of you taking
photos throughout the talk.
But if you haven't
taken any yet,
this is the one
slide that you really
should take a picture of.
Here in one place are all of the
different tips we've given you
about how to make use of
the existing features,
as well as the new ones.
Success for both of us
after this talk, I think,
is the same thing,
that you come away
with some concrete
next steps on something
that you can do within our
health tools that will help
you reach your business goals.
So please do take
a picture, have
a look at what
we're recommending,
and think about which
of these actions
that you might be able to take
and try when you get back home.
We also have office hours.
I think it's 3:30--
so pretty much soon
after this talk--
if you want to come and discuss
with any of us the topics
we've been through today.
Another resource that you can
look at when you're back home
is on the Play Academy,
where we offer free training
to all developers.
It was built to
help you understand
best practices and features
to help you succeed on Play.
And we have dedicated content
on that from this year's I/O.
So to wrap up, I
just wanted to repeat
what I said at the start.
Quality is a job
that is never done.
For as long as Android
continues to evolve, for as long
as new form factors are created,
and you, developers, continue
to innovate, we
have the potential
to create all kinds of amazing
capabilities and experiences
for users.
And throughout
all these changes,
the thing that remains
constant for us
is to maintain and increase
the baseline for quality
on Android.
So you should expect to
see us again here next year
and at many other
events in between.
Please also do keep sharing
your feedback with us,
in the meantime,
and help us partner
with you on this
long-term journey.
Thank you very
much for listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]